new at noon today a campaign to recycle
used clothing across
seven cities made its way to las vegas
today it's to raise awareness of the
millions of pounds of clothes that end
up in u.s landfills every year
hector mejia is live in the downtown
arts district with those details hey
hector
hey there good afternoon it all starts
at four o'clock later on today people
invited to bring in a pile of used
clothing and maybe exchange it for
one of these cool pieces it's a big push
by the brand
lg part of a campaign to not only raise
awareness about the piles and piles
millions of piles of clothing that pile
up in landfills but also it's an effort
to collect clothing
for families in need and joining us live
we have michael who's a brand
representative for lg electronics usa
all right so talk to us about that big
mission thanks hector we're really
excited to be out here in the las vegas
arts district at 18 bin
we are running our second life tour
which is really all about getting people
excited about caring for what they wear
and reducing their fashion footprint
and it's tying a big company with an
important mission which is giving back
absolutely you know about 81 pounds per
year that's the number
that's the weight worth of clothing that
average americans are throwing away
every single year that's
millions of pounds annually we want to
help reduce that carbon
footprint so we're out here encouraging
folks to come by
donate their unwanted clothing items
they can toss it
right into one of our lg wash towers
everything donated into this bin here is
going to be taken to
a wash center that we've built out in
los angeles which is
full of lg wash towers and steamers
we're going to clean them sanitize them
and send them off to beneficiaries
around the country so briefly before we
run out of time
4 pm to 8 pm today big goal is to
collect
10 000 pounds of clothing across seven
cities is that right that's exactly
right we need your help so come on out
to the arts district
we'll be here until eight p.m all right
thank you very much so that's what's
going on here in the arts district
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now back to you alex